l'invité de sortie vishal branchies sur
la liste du parti communiste français
pour les européennes du week-end du 25
et 26 mai bon jean michel branchi
bonjour maurice violland bonjour à tous
les auditeurs et auditrices vont figurer
donc sur la liste menée par ian brossât
en 17e position c'est une liste celle de
yann grosses sommes
avec le parti communiste français qui se
veut celle de la france qui travaille
oui c'est une liste qui après un flot
originalité de d'une part d'avoir une
vision d'une autre europe cette europe
qui a déçu la majorité des citoyens
européens et qui veut une europe des
nations souveraines libre été associés
et nous par du communisme en tunique est
je vais peut être que le parti
communiste martiniquais n'est plus une
fédération du parti communiste français
nous sommes au travail et ensemble nous
nous sommes retrouvés dans cette
orientation qui en gros qui permet à la
martinique en tant qu'entité en tant qu
entité culturelle en tant qu entité
géographique et qui n'est pas l'europe
de défendre ses intérêts face à l'autre
sur la liste sur le site internet de de
votre liste vous dites vouloir incarner
des hommes et des femmes en colère
contre emmanuel macron et une volonté de
vivre dignement
vous allez profiter de cette élection
européenne pour faire de l'actualité
franco françaises n'ont pas du tout même
nous allons faire de l'actualité
européenne parce que l'actualité
européenne a une incidence chez
l'actualité française et sur l'actualité
martiniquaise
je prends un exemple pour un exemple les
les mesures de macron concernant le code
du travail sont largement inspirés par
la philosophie et des dieux active
européenne concernant le coût du travail
donc par conséquent c'est artificiel que
de séparer aujourd'hui ce qui serait
strictement européen serait ce qui
serait strictement français
et concernant la martinique nous avons
un challenge s'est informé nos
compatriotes qui ne le sont pas assez
que beaucoup de décisions qui vivent de
boules de situation qu'ils vivent
souvent dépend de décisions qui sont
prises dans dans l'opacité et dans le
silence au niveau européen comment
l'expliquez cela michel branchi nous
sommes quand même en 2019 l'europe ça
date pas d'hier
toute affaire quand même d'un certain
nombre d'années de certain nombre de
décennies
comment expliquer que les martiniquais
ce roi un peu des extraterrestres ne
savent pas que certaines choses décide
de son décidée par bruxelles et depuis
bruxelles
je pense que s'ils ne sont pas les seuls
parce que les sondages montrent que la
plupart des opinions publiques
européennes sont mal informés sur les
institutions européennes
mais s'agissant s'agissant de la
martinique je pense qu'il ya liées à
l'éloignement géographique et à
l'éloignement culturel la réalité c'est
que la martinique l es l et es les
places européennes elles et caribéennes
et par conséquent nous sommes des hommes
politiques des femmes politiques et les
gens les hommes alors qu'ils peuvent
mener certaines actions sur le terrain
parce qu'il ya des financements
européens qui arrivent dans cette année
quelque chose vous ne cherchiez à sanaa
m tout à fait tout à fait nous tous à
nos quignard doigt toute construction
toujours ni financé par l'europe
oui alors nous sommes justement nous
sommes de ceux qui qui ne disent pas
l'europe c'est simplement de l'argent
nous disons que l'europe s'ils ont
développé un faux dit la chose suivante
les fonds européens
grosso modo à l'investissement pas au
fonctionnement 115 millions par an tard
dans le pot ap la programmation 2014
2020 le bénéfice que le retire du
commerce ahk la martinique ses 315
millions donc nous ne sommes pas
simplement des mendiants non ce que je
vois un flux qui de qui méritait il
s'est infiltré d'être expliqué alors
c'est un flic mérite d'être expliquée et
c c'est ce que nous tentons de faire
avec nous avec les moyens qui sont les
nôtres
un bon nous sommes encore un parti le
parti communiste pour sa part tous
sympas et ce qui dépend de lui
ils sont encore en partie qui dispose
d'un hebdo banner
nous sommes nous faisons l'effort chaque
semaine et si on veut savoir les
positions du parti communiste s'est pas
c'est pas difficile suffit d'acheter
justice je suis vu d'assez justice
qu'ils enquêtent et d'ailleurs dû aux
smartphones tout à fait et chevauchée
qui va fêter l'année prochaine le son
100ème annulation je bouffe de
l'occasion de le dire
michel branchi une liste qui se veut le
reflet d'une france en colère si on
regarde ce qui se passe en france mais
également ici à fort de france
si ces personnes qui sont en colère et
retraités les enseignants la santé oms
va arrêter la liste vous devriez être
normalement à plus de 300 % des
intentions de vote pour le 26 mai bien
écouter entre la colère la compréhension
de la cause de la colère et
l'identification de ceux qui sont
responsables
c'est justement c'est ça l'action
politique on peut être en colère tue
tous les jours on entend ça dans les
coups de gueule on peut être en colère
protester contre l'eau le chemin vicinal
ou non c'est bien seulement
bien souvent les citoyens à l'epad
compte tenu de la glace on l'appelle le
millefeuille n'at il pas toujours à
identifier qui est responsable de quoi
donc c'est ça le alors nous avons il ya
à la fois la presse nous mêmes les
partis politiques ça j'en prends trop
mon grade les partis politiques les
cycles et les hommes politiques les
organisations politiques
il est aussi aussi la la le droit de
citoyenneté que pente après on attend la
liste renaissance 1 celle prônée par
emmanuel macron le président de la
république est en tête avec également
celle du rassemblement national
il ya quand même sacré et comptera ce
serait très paradoxe avec cette france
en colère qui pourrait prêter du doigt
certains dessins sont jamais les
sondages elle est les sondages ne font
pas l'élection
un bon je pourrais vous citer de
nombreux cas comme il qu'un de
martinique dans le monde pour la
martinique on la veut donner letchimy
vainqueur o
c'était au ctm à la province et m
et c'est marie jeanne gagné non par
conséquent vous savez oui vous dites
avec votre liste promouvoir une vraie
transformation transformation de l'union
européenne pour une europe des gens
et pas une europe de l'argent quand on a
besoin de l'argent pour la faire
fonctionner cette oui mais là alors
c'est une robe qui est au service des
forces de l'argent ça veut pas alors je
prends l'exemple
là-bas la banque centrale européenne
elle a distribué trois mille milliards
après la crise de 2008-2009 la copie
financière du capitalisme d'ailleurs aux
banques
or aujourd'hui la croissance est atone
on est à un vieux 2% de croissance en
moyenne européenne
le/la l'allemagne kehl le le moteur de
l'économie est pratiquement récession
l'italie est en récession
en conséquence le problème c'est pas
l'argent seulement l'utilisation de
l'argent et concernant le joueur vient à
nous mêmes parce que nous sommes là pour
défendre nos intérêts l'argent l'argent
que nous utilisons poule pour
l'investissement et bien les fonds
européens et les questions de les
diminuer on les questions dans dans la
voix la politique puis d'anciens postes
2020 en notamment raison de bauxite de
faire passer la martinique en amp et en
régions en transition c'est-à-dire
région qui suit vous développez alors
tout simplement parce que le pib dépasse
75% du pays de loiron berry et qu'est ce
que ce qu'est michel branchi qu'on
ralentisse un peu certaines
constructions pour démontrer à leurs
yeux à l'europe que nous avons besoin
encore de succès nous avons deux ans les
subventions notamment dans le transport
par exemple nous avons nous avons un
grand défi c'est dans le val d'oise elle
va devoir des politiques est tout
simplement qu'il faudrait peut être
revoir et oui tout à fait l'argent il ya
eu oui non à l'or l'argent et les
flécher probablement l'europe l'europe
donne l'argent elle donne quand même
pour le donner c'est bon elle a mis en
place ce qui fait que le fonds européen
je compare les fonds européens à un
jambon qui est placée au dessus de mât
de cocagne avec de la glu pour
l'attraper faut faire beaucoup de
démagogie
ouais nan faut simplifier et la
procédure pour attraper les fonds
européens
et puis deuxièmement vous pas le flécher
dans les secteurs qui ne sont pas qui ne
sont pas des secteurs prioritaires
nous avons encore des besoins en matière
d'infrastructures donc par conséquent on
sait qu'ils allaient voter le 26 mai
pour la liste du parti communiste
français
comment ferez vous campagne à michel
branchi sert martinique ben nous ferons
campagne en faisant durer
nous allons faire une conférence de
presse dans l'enfer de publier un
manifeste
nous avons publié un nous avons un
comité de soutien qui est présidée par
armand nicolas qui est une personnalité
que qui est maintenant devenu bien qui a
été sauvée d'un jeune parti qui domine
tant ce courant qui est un personnalité
qui fait le consensus
et puis nous allons aller à la rencontre
des citoyens et puis je pense que vous
avez vous allez nous inviter deux il y
aura des débats contradictoires pour
montrer que tous les candidats aux
élections européennes ne défendent pas
tout à fait la même chose
l'europe des gens l'europe des nations
libres et souveraines associé à l'europe
et non et non pas l'intégration la
dilution la dissolution de la mort
d'unique dans l'europe
merci michel branchi d'avoir été ce
matin avec nos centres a dit on rappelle
que voulait pas le seul ressortissant
dirigions extrait hexagonal être sur
cette liste puisqu'il ya également en
sixième position
la réunionnaise julie pontalba
totalement qui sont 17e position
aucun membre du parti communiste de la
réunion lequel a été le parti qui a
s'est battu pour la reconnaissance des
spécificités uni au sein de l'europe
merci michel manche cig journée merci
d'abriter dans son crédit merci beaucoup
monsieur wolton m'avoir invité
[Musique]